let's go back into the build here josh i
guess we'll go to my screen if you will
and i'm going to go into the customize
the customize menu here up at the top
jerry i thought we might just kind of
run through a few of these things and
then
we'll kind of just navigate through the
the world of customization
as it exists in this build which as you
already know it is it's just a subset of
what we can expect to find in
the shipping game so i think we'll just
go down the list here people are
probably very eager i assume they've
never seen this by the way
i do like this aisle animation you let
it sit and just kind of cycles through
some really cool um
sort of 3d assets yeah which is nice
the other cool thing is like you just
pop into customization you already know
we're doing a
a lot more and you know it's great to
hear sam and you notice some of the
customization that's going on with bots
and in your own hands with well uh you
know with your
uh ar uh that's all that's all in the
game
uh for for people to play with all right
well let's start by going in the armor
hall and then we're just gonna kind of
quickly move through here and then we'll
you know we'll kind of bounce around
like you and i discuss so armor hall
pretty self-explanatory this is where
i'm going to customize my spartan's
armor right so
um right away here we go um now for this
tech preview
because it's a subset i'm going to have
one armor core and that's going to be my
mark 7
armor core and you know jerry you and i
have discussed this a little bit
just there's been a lot of questions i
think in the community since we first
started talking about armor cores right
and we've we've
demonstrated this and sort of showed it
off in our old overview video and some
prior blogs
so how would you sort of best describe
like what is an armor core and sort of
how should we think about that
yeah so this is one of our new our new
systems so christopher blum
and jeremy have done a really great job
here
uh creating this system you know one of
the things when we step back and design
we wanted to
wanted to rethink how do we help make
sure that our players
uh are really represented as characters
when you take a look at
spartan armor it's like strapping on an
f-22
or maybe you want a set of armor that is
like an m1 abrams tank
right each one of those vehicles is
unique and has a unique character
um the other great thing about that the
the thing we're trying to build is we're
trying to make sure that the character
of that armor
really comes through there's really no
better way to show this than
um hey josh you have uh
one of the pictures one of the concept
pictures yeah
okay so everyone saw at the end of that
amazing multiplayer trailer the
the samurai armor when we talk about
strapping on a piece of armor as a
unique character
i think i think our first fracture core
and that's we call these fractures
because they're they're not part of the
main canon they're part of
basically side universes uh that you can
that you can look at
you can look at how we're trying to
develop the character and our artists
have done an amazing job of really
trying to represent
the breadth of what we want to look at
maintaining the character
uh throughout the entire armor set and
more importantly allowing that
customization
and you as a player saying hey look when
i strap on
that's armor you know that samurai armor
tank
i want to make sure that i can make it
mine and this is the breath
in which we can we can really express
but stay within the character we don't
want everyone to feel like they're just
all one part of a single uh a single
vehicle basically
and so then you can look at what what
what
the artists have been able to think
about and you take a look at the
attachments that you're seeing there
you're seeing swords you're seeing
you know a bandolier you're seeing
grenades you're seeing different hip
pieces you're seeing
daggers you're seeing darts you're
seeing a whole different expression of
what
a samurai could look at could look like
and that's that's pretty critical for us
to help at least in this first
impression in our first moment for
everyone at launch
um because remember at a live game
perspective we are expecting everyone to
provide feedback what works what doesn't
works what do you want to see more
and that's where the game will grow as
we move forward yep
this is awesome by the way i'm super
excited by the uh roy samurai in
particular which which by the way we've
also confirmed will be
um one of the first free pieces of
content that players can earn
in season one by just completing a free
event yeah
absolutely and again that that type of
completion where
just playing the game and earning things
is still a part of not only our dna but
again from
a free-to-play game we want to make sure
that we provide multiple avenues not
just the battle pass
but you have different ways and we'll
show that um as as we go forward
different ways in which you can earn
things
yeah right now i'm just kind of cycling
through the weapon bench just to give
uh you know give our viewers a sense of
what that looks like so you know if i
were to equip
weapon coatings i could check them out
here um i'm just sort of scrolling
through giving people a chance to see
some of the some of the weapons that
they uh we have in the game currently
that they'll be able to check out so
i really love this feature this is so
sweet because every time you pick up a
weapon
right you take it off the weapon pad it
is your weapon
and it'll be skinned the way you want it
to it it'll it'll look the way you want
it to
it is it is just a sweet sweet um
feeling
let's quickly jump in the vehicle bay i
mean one big quick caveat here is none
of the experiences in this tech preview
bill will let you
drive vehicles this time around but of
course vehicles are an integral part of
our sandbox huge part of the experience
especially with the return of big team
battle
yeah so we're going to get to that a
little bit later this year but i'll just
kind of give people a quick glimpse here
um of some of the updated models some of
these things we're seeing for the first
time i believe yeah and again for the
what we're showing here from a
customization perspective
you make this you so you're you get to
say hey look no when i drive my
warthog or when i get on my razor back
with my team
i'm the driver i get into it first it's
going to look the way that
that that i want it to look like and so
as you continue to play and you're in
the community
you're going to have different looks
from from players and everyone will know
like it is you in the driver's seat all
right then i'm going to jump down one
more real quick here in the body and ai
um this one you know we we obviously
have a couple different body types i can
choose choose from
i'm really i really love actually the
the depth that we've been able to go to
now for prosthetics right just an
additional layer of customization and
frankly inclusivity as well
yeah sure i mean the biggest thing is
just about you know from a philosophy
perspective for
for player first is we want everyone to
be able to represent themselves
you know my sisters actually does build
prosthetics for a living
and this is very important is it's a
part of your identity
it's also quite frankly some of it's
really cool
and again we're only showing a very
small subset so don't get lost in that
um but the sheer fact that you can do
your your entire body the way you want
to
from a product prosthetic perspective
and really make this
your identity is really really critical
for us
so personal ai is another new addition
to the game we
introduced this uh people heard uh some
personal ai in the mp trailer for
example i know there's a lot of people
out there that became instant fans of
lumu for example
um and i think you know we'll talk more
about this probably with tom french in a
bit and we'll see it
in action in some of our additional
footage but you know it's just a subset
right so
there's and it's also just the beginning
like this is the
this is the biggest thing we have so
many things in which you can really
express yourself
um you know the way you want to and even
your
your ai sidekick it's yours to express
like it's yours to make yours and i
think
the cool thing is that when you see when
you see tom talk about you see the modes
you're going to use it in
it really becomes a part of the
personality that you bring to the field
yeah and you know each each ai here for
example has their own unique voice their
own unique personality it's really fun
and then you can go one step further if
you want to and actually even
you know a subset of colors as well so
personal ais are one of my favorite
additions to the game apparently and i
can't wait for for players to experience
more of that
um and then you know we have one more
grayed out area here and this is where
i'd be able to do stuff like my service
tag and emblem and
you know i think you've alluded to
there's more coming than what's in this
build so we want people to stay tuned
um now i think you know let's quickly i
want to keep things moving here because
i know folks are eager we got a lot to
get through
um how about we you want to jump over to
the battle pass yeah let's see maybe
we'll switch